hey daddy are you a cg person well look
at my lips
i think my favorite like effect overall
from this whole video are the dancing
robots watching here they didn't replace
a lot of these faces
[Laughter]
so these underwater shots are something
i kind of want to talk about because a
lot of people like we're kind of fooled
i mean really all we did was just
hi welcome back to another episode of
vfx rs react today we're joined by my
close friend mike aka mike diva here is
an acclaimed music video director it's a
pleasure to be here yeah i'm very
honored
well thank you so i started doing a lot
of vfx work myself for my videos mostly
out of necessity a lot of youtube stuff
i did like this video dubstep guns with
you guys a lot of it was just me kind of
learning the program and kind of just
doing what i had to do to get the dumb
stuff in my head out into the world and
now i'm mostly focused on directing but
it really helps to come from the visual
effects background to really fully be
able to direct for that sort of thing
all right what's the first thing we're
looking at here
for those of you who don't know mike
recently directed the panini music video
for lil mass ex
[Laughter]
is the whitest anybody has ever said
that it was intentional
[Music]
we had five days to from like getting
the job to like shooting the video i
literally had to shoot a previz to kind
of act out the whole video and make sure
that it works and like the concept works
the best way i like to do it is by doing
what i call a crap-o-matic which you
guys have messed with before as well but
it's basically a storyboard that you
just shot on your phone just to kind of
give the general idea of what to expect
right yeah yeah and it's really good for
figuring out like exactly what works in
the shot what doesn't framing action
basically directing the whole video
before i direct the video and then that
way i know exactly what cuts together
and like what doesn't wow look at that
this is pretty good running from the
holograms we use a lot of
a lot of avengers action figures there
we literally got these action figures
for previous purposes and there's me
reacting to my dancing
[Laughter]
you're not much a performer at 2am you
know it's dancing wasn't that bad we
didn't know the lyrics
josh was like trying to read them off
his phone
and i'm like you're like what are you
reading off your phone
panini smiles we were putting together
this video at 4 am in the morning the
day it was due the day it was like
pretty much uploaded and
okay yeah it was one of those like
there's like literally like so many vfx
shots in every single shot we worked
with the vfx house chimney to to do this
but also i had my own team on the side
that was doing stuff like this car shot
and all the window replacement and stuff
like that but if you back up to that
shot of her walking up to the car this
is one of the shots that when i received
it at 3 30 in the morning i noticed that
the layer that she was on was
transparent and you could see the car
landing in front of her head oh no and
uh someone accidentally left the opacity
of her layer at like 70
or even like just 98 just enough that
you can see the car going through your
head yeah i've been there i've seen that
in my own final renders and i'm just
like no
there was nothing i could do i literally
just had to boost the contrast a ton
so that you couldn't tell but like it's
still technically the messed up shot but
like so this shot right here there are
so many neon light type effects in the
shot how many of those are practical
like i see some stuff like a sign there
like a little smiley face those are the
smiley face signs are like the only real
signs in the scene and then like those
purple neon bars in the background for a
scene like this what i did was i motion
tracked the scene in after effects and i
had a bunch of different elements made
and i placed everything in the scene
where i wanted it you know so i had a
bunch of fake brands made place them in
the scene and then i gave them to the
vfx house and went do this but better
and then for this stuff i was literally
like animating and compositing the
little nos hologram effects like the
morning of truly hours before it got
released
[Music]
so wirework sucks and i hate it
that's my takeaway from this so for this
scene she couldn't actually wear the
backpack because like it got caught up
in with the wire work so that's a 100 cg
backpack right there wow we literally
had like black gaff tape
that was
just like there's just black tape on our
shoulders wow and they're like that's
good enough so mike as you know this
show is called vfx artists react to bad
and great cgi yes we haven't talked
about any bad cgi yet we haven't i have
one for you though clue from tron legacy
look at you man
look at the size again i feel like this
kind of touches upon some of the kind of
uncanny valley stuff that you guys have
talked about before and the tech just
like not quite been there yet but what's
interesting with this one is that like i
feel like it was kind of that in-between
right but i feel like this was also like
10 years ago that they were making this
right
that big reveal
i bet you they thought this was gonna be
like an oh [ __ ] moment
like oh
his head feels like it's got like no
weight to it i feel like this is right
up here alley mike because of all like
the neon lights and whatnot like like
light designs you know well this movie
was directed by a designer
not in the cards it's kind of got the
playstation face going on he's got polar
express face polar express i wouldn't
say that i think it actually doesn't
look that bad i think the lighting helps
a lot but the moment he starts talking
every time anytime a cg phase starts
talking it falls apart instantly i'm not
your father sam now i couldn't be in
there all the time so man it kind of
does stand out though oh now yeah the
side profile now he looks there's
something about his profile like it just
doesn't yeah it's like really smooth the
kids even like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
but they're doing a pretty good job of
like making them very edge lit and so
every most of this face facing the
camera is in shadow so you're not really
seeing too many details there it sells
enough yeah but the shot when he opens
the door and turns around it all falls
apart hey daddy are you a cg person well
look at my lips
[Music]
well
that's the way it goes
i'm gonna go to the arcade i'll see you
later
nico do you know what exactly is wrong
with his skin in that shot though yeah i
think i do actually is it the plastic
look like i mean what's going on here
the pores don't stretch you're missing
out on the micro details of the surface
specifically the stubble and the facets
of the skin so you know snow sparkles of
course of course everybody knows how
snow sparkles right yeah it's the magic
of christmas mark it's all sparkly and
on your face all your pores are
reflecting light here and there like
there are straight up sparkles on your
cheek
there's not really any of that on his
skin and yeah they have like a bump map
to kind of like break up the reflections
outside of just your skin being rough
and having surface detail your skin also
has hair on it and maybe they're trying
to do the hair but whatever they're
doing here is not working and this is a
this is a great example if you look at
thanos from adventures he has stubble on
his chin and these little bits of hair
are sticking out are catching the light
and casting shadow and even when you're
not on your beard area even on the rest
of your face you still have hair on your
face like you have peach fuzz on your
cheeks these hairs are all missing
because that's an extra million and
millions of millions of polygons we're
always on the same team now what about
the subsurface scattering aspect cause
you know the amount of transparency
actually varies depending on where your
skin is located you're definitely right
you know here on the cheeks is a little
bit thicker versus like right over the
eyebrow or over the nose it's a little
bit thinner but it's definitely an issue
here like the tip of his nose like the
cartilage where the cartilage ends in
your nose you still just have flesh so
that very tip of his nose and the little
like line underneath your nose should be
like kind of glowing red from the light
going through it it's close but it's not
quite there i think that's a lot of it
is that you don't have like the redness
here and the redness that goes here and
like the basic stuff that they teach you
like in art school about painting a
human being it's like there's that
redness that you need so you have real
skin right the arms and the arms are
basically in the same spot as the face
relative to that light so if you keep
playing here tell me in your opinion do
the highlights on his face match the
highlights on his arms no
but his face is closer to the lamp
though look at his bottom right forearm
and his face yes his face is much more
lit it feels like the light source is
the lamp is here but it feels like the
light source on his face is like more
like here and not just that look at the
difference in the highlights the edge
light there on his face there's light
wrap on the bottom of his chin there's
like a very pretty strong highlight edge
along his entire face but on his bicep
there isn't that little white line
there's a little bit on his forearm
there where his hair on his forearm is
catching the light but not on his skin
there's a clear bright white lion on his
chin and there's no clear bright white
line on his bicep all of a sudden the
lighting itself feels faked and you know
what it is hold on mike i want you to
react to something else here real quick
okay oh it says artist and it's all key
frames tracking
bit bezier bezier curves my reaction is
i think this is a really cool shirt
quarter digital joggers ooh i actually
oh
these are very cool i would wear them
out of these we've brought back a little
bit of a classic design with a twist now
that's dope eight bit design so i get to
keep these yes sick thank you chord dude
i don't even have those joggers
shut up
bash brothers was my baby of the year as
they say
i can't even do it right hold on
there we go that's a bash
that's a bad
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'm mark so yeah i got the
opportunity to co-direct this netflix
special for those who don't know it's
about the bash brothers who were two
baseball players in the early 90s that i
had no idea who they were before getting
the opportunity to do this and i also
hate baseball so there's that i kind of
took it upon myself to really make this
as visually interesting as possible for
people that you know aren't baseball
fans and obviously the rest of the load
is carried by andy sandberg and akiva
shaffer being hilarious
i love you i do it's pretty incredible
thanks man yeah i i really wanted to do
a hype williams video and that was kind
of the idea behind this whole thing was
just like
really like with each song because they
just dumped all these songs in my lap
we're like what should we do and so this
one i had like the energy of like a hype
williams video and i just kind of tried
to hit like the kind of sped up like
like filming them with like the song
slowed down and then speeding it up and
all that good stuff and really this is
like filming that hallway scene was the
moment it hit me and i was like wow i
really get to like dress up my heroes in
funny costumes and like make them do
what i want and it was the most surreal
thing in the world like that they were
all just on board for this such an
amazing thing i actually approached andy
sandberg eight years ago in a sushi
restaurant and i told him like just want
to say
you're my hero and keep doing what
you're doing and i shook his hand and
i'll never tell him about that he still
doesn't know to this day that i did that
so these underwater shots are something
i kind of want to talk about because a
lot of people like were kind of fooled
and they thought that we actually like
shot some stuff underwater i mean really
all we did was just blow fans at them
and had them lay back on apple boxes
with a green sheet and just shot it
super slow motion
uh and just the the subtle movement in
their hair and stuff like that kind of
sells it so film in slow motion with a
very powerful fan uh-huh and that can
kind of like help emulate the underwater
look
oh fun fact about that dick shot so he
says whip out my dick on the jumbotron
and i actually had peter france buy a cg
dick off of
i bought a cg dick off of turbosquid and
i had him animate like a dick like
flopping around oh my god
oh my god and the ideal peter the idea
was to blur it out and he like you know
he rolled up his sleeves and it made it
work and like made it very realistic
wait wait did you use soft body physics
or rigid body soft body physics
it looked so good that when you watch
the shot you're like ugh did akiva just
really just whip his dick out right
there so at the last minute before we
turned it into netflix i like threw the
black bar on it so you really did just
make peter do that i made peter make a
day
for no reason at all
i want to talk about fixing your
shortcomings as a director via visual
effects the transitional line in the
song is me and jose got a smash back to
ihop and i got this shot on the day and
i never got a shot of the car like
pulling up oh and i just completely
spaced it on that i was just in post
trying to figure out how to cut these
two scenes together and i was like well
flying car
unexplained you never see it again they
never talk about it it's just you just
they have a flying car i guess and so i
made a background plate i like
photoshopped a background plate by
smashing together like three different
shots that we had and then literally
just bought a model car off of uh
turbosquid and modified it and then boom
it works
anyways that's bash brothers real quick
i know it's not vfx but what was it like
working with andy and akiva
it was a dream man it was it was like
like a combination of like i'm very
nervous and i hope i don't mess this up
because again these guys like i grew up
with these guys like pre youtube kind of
like what got me into like doing what i
do and the other part was the stress of
we have four days to shoot six music
videos
how do we do that so it was it was truly
the most insane shoot i've ever been on
so there's a day on set where you had me
come out to be an extrovert but there's
a moment where i got to talk to andy
samberger it's just me and him back in
video village we're just talking about
how great of a director you are oh
sorry andy sandberg said that you're
really good oh that was my heart until
he remembers that you uh wait he's like
after that sushi bar eight years ago
also i want to mention real quick a lot
of our ideas for things to react to come
from you guys so please leave a comment
with a movie tv show whatever it is
you'd like us to react to to break it
down to tell you how it's made all right
let's jump back in
you guys already did a video where you
mentioned burly brawl right talking
about matrix reloaded yes the classic
matrix reloaded scene
i love the choreography
yeah and in the video you guys talked
about like the good points of it what do
you guys think get it off your channel
i want to talk about the things that
don't work in this scene there is some
really really great choreography in the
scene and some great action but then
they do some really really bizarre
unnatural unnecessary stuff that i just
feel like makes the scene
goofy in my opinion
right here what is that move
whoa
i don't know it's just so weird to me
and i feel like it just kind of breaks
it this and the shot of him running over
the agent's heads
it looks weird but i feel like that's
the intent for them to make it look
awkward not awkward i mean it's it's
different
i mean this is just a weird directing
choice i think they're in mary poppins
it gets very cute and then there's that
scene where they they put the bowling
pins getting knocked over
and it goes like full cartoon an actual
like bowling pin sound effect
when you're going to be pushing the
threshold with what you can do in cg you
have to make sure you're not just like
getting so ridiculous that your design
choices and choreography choices in the
movie itself are going to ruin the time
that's what i mean i feel like it breaks
it kind of like how you guys talk about
in pacific rim the difference between
pacific rim one and two the camera feels
grounded and it feels like you're you
know you're getting shots that cameras
can feasibly get and that's why the
robots feel huge and real also the fact
that they slow down moments like this
that i feel like the the cg is not good
enough to fully slow down and the name
specifically the way the cloth moves
like the cloth's weight changes
completely like you're talking about his
his jacket yeah like it feels so much
more lightweight and the way it's
flowing right there does not sell to me
at all it works for me personally it
doesn't for me and that's because the
simulation detail is not high enough for
that cloth i'd agree with that look at
how many wrinkles are on his right arm
there and now look at how he wrinkles on
his arm there
yeah it's all smooth it's all smooth
it's like the same thing with surface
imperfections when you're rendering like
glass or anything reflective you gotta
have like something to kind of break it
up and make it look a little bit more
messy so that being so smooth is kind of
giving it a weird fake look what you're
seeing here is basically the kind of
cloth sims you get in like a modern day
basketball game on like the playstation
4.
so mike you're like i could tell those
weren't cg human beings each one of
those heads are 100 cg and they look
perfect they do dude the battle from
middle earth would have gone so much
better if they had this many elronds
around
hugo weaving it had to be like every
once in a while like the one guy that
comes in and punches and his face
happens to like be facing the camera in
each one of those sequences okay it's
like five stuntmen then hugo waiting and
like five more stun men and then hugo
weaving comes running in well that guy
wait when he grabs his shoulder go back
come back enhance oh that guy on the
left
who that is
you're a cowboy right there how about
this something on the sides there's
hebrew weaving that guy right there yeah
yeah hey
it's amazing how much you don't see this
oh yeah actually all of this is
inconsequential like you're like really
mad i thought they were all replaced but
watching it here they didn't replace a
lot of these faces they just left them
as is because you can't tell
i didn't
like that guy the entire scene they
don't replace his face look at him he's
just chilling the entire scene he's just
standing there like ready to punch he's
on the ground he's bummed when i get my
chance i'm gonna punch him
i like this game that's enough that's
enough
still an incredible technical
achievement still amazing too much
respect respect it still gives to us
mike diva thank you for coming out thank
you so much for having me you can follow
him on instagram yes mike diva mike diva
truly an honor to be here with you guys
uh let me just disappear real quick
just kidding we're not doing the effects
it didn't work you at least put like a
smoke plume so it looks like something
happened yeah subscribe wow i can't
believe i got my very own corridor
digital merch
now in stores right cornerdigital.store
there's a link in the description below
buying merch is a great way to help
support the show and support what we do
here at corridor and you know we
actually have free returns so if for
some reason you don't like it it's
absolutely no sweat off your back is
that the saying no sweat off your back
yeah it's no sweat off your back
corridor digital it's no sweat off your
back